let's talk about the influence of
intermittent fasting over the
cardiovascular system there are so many
benefits from intermittent fasting but
the benefit to the heart is a major
major benefit so it all starts with
lowering insulin okay so when you fast
you decrease insulin and insulin
controls what type of fuel that the
body's going to run on what type of fuel
that the heart will run on and it just
so happens that fatty acids from fat
cells are the main source of fuel to the
heart and your heart prefers a type of
ketone acetoacetate to glucose so this
is just one of the three types of
ketones the problem is when you're
running your body on glucose you don't
have as much oxygen and you're getting a
lot more waste in co2 so fasting
switches your body from glucose to
ketones but when you eat it's inverted
you go from ketosis to glucose and the
other interesting thing about ketones is
that they have the ability to feed the
heart if the heart is in a damaged state
so if you have any type of
cardiovascular disease your heart will
benefit greatly from fasting and
providing ketones with a low-carb diet
also you'll see improvement we have
atherosclerosis your arteries will
become less stiff your blood pressure
can come down and your improving insulin
resistance which automatically will
increase your ability to absorb
electrolytes so you'll have more
electrolyte function and you'll have
less problems with the rhythm of the
heart like you'll have less palpitations
and less problems with things like
atrial fibrillation because the
pacemaker of the heart which controls a
rhythm needs the electrolytes and when
you have insulin resistance you're not
going to be able to absorb the quantity
of electrolytes now one little point
about the liver when you're doing
fasting you are depleting the storage of
glucose it's called glycogen and if your
body needs glucose it has the ability to
make glucose in the liver it's called
gluconeogenesis this means new making
new glucose
from ketones from other things from fat
like glycerol so when your body needs
glucose and it makes it it's not
dangerous but when you get clothes from
the diet that's when it becomes
dangerous not only does it create
massive oxidation with the inside of the
arteries but it triggers insulin and it
stops this process from happening it
doesn't allow you to release ketones and
fatty acids as much and your body just
becomes dependent on glucose so and if
the glucose that increased the risk for
damage within the artery lining the
endothelial layer of the inside of the
arteries and when it's damaged it
attracts certain types of cholesterol to
heal it and calcium and it forms
plaquing and then that can break off and
cause a stroke or clog the artery
directly alright guys there you have it
but if intermittent fasting is something
that interests you check out these
additional videos on this page